[Music]
it's all about solving problems it's not
about like maybe in previous years
you've done a multiplication table
memorization it's not like memorizing
how to solve problems it's learning the
tools to how of how to solve problems
and then using them um and building them
up in creative ways so it's kind of like
it really does remind me of art because
if you are doing like a painting or
something you have like a specific tools
about like maybe paint brushes or
different techniques you can use um to
create something bigger um so i feel
like algebra is really all about
combining things that you already know
how to do um into something bigger so
the word algebra
comes from the arabic word algebra that
literally translates to
reunion of broken parts
this breaking apart of mathematic
representations
and putting it back together in the form
of balanced equations is the essence of
algebra and the beautiful thing is that
this
balancing and solving of equations can
be done in many different ways which is
where creativity comes in